hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast close your uncertainty gap
with high resolution mass spectrometry I
am Judy O'Rourke of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's webcast is presented by lab
routes comm the leading social media
site for science professionals and
sponsored by thermo fisher a world
leader in serving science whose mission
is to enable customers to make the world
healthier cleaner and safer thermo
fisher scientific helps their customers
accelerate life sciences research solve
complex analytical challenges improve
patient diagnostics and increased
laboratory productivity for more
information please visit www thermo
scientific calm before we start there
are a few instructions we want to hear
from you during this interactive
broadcast so please ask questions or
leave us a comment answer is welcome to
you can do this by hitting the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window and typing in your
comments and questions we'll try to get
to as many as we can and we'll follow up
if we don't have time today want a
better look you can enlarge the slide
window by clicking on the screen icon in
the lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you can't hear or see this
presentation properly let us know by
clicking on the support button on the
top right or use the Q&A button we'll
make sure we try to resolve any issues
now let's get right to today's
presenters we are proud to welcome
christine van natta strategic marketing
application specialist with thermo
fisher scientific and monterey primorsky
in your application scientist with
thermo fisher scientific our first
speaker is dr. Maura Murphy he received
his master's science and physics from
the University of Manitoba Canada
followed by a business degree at
Georgetown University in the USA ma che
started his career at mastek
incorporated as a research scientist
working on novel task instrumentation he
then moved to Europe to work for waters
in the product support specialist upon
his return to you
say much a rejoined mastek and in five
years progressively moved to become the
director of business development for all
ap Mulvey ion sources since mid-2010
machi drives the development and global
marketing of the q executive portfolio
product out of bremen germany i will now
turn it over to dr. bro mirsky okay
thank you journey for the for the kind
introduction and thanks to all for
joining this today's webinar so my
webinar presentation will focus on
closing the uncertainty gaps and
forensic toxicology labs with
high-resolution packet mass instrument
so and the focus of my presentation will
would be on the key England used product
key objective focus mass spectrometer
which was introduced a year ago at soft
conference 2014 in grand rapids in UF so
before I jump into the really core of my
presentation like to give you a quick
overview of thermo fisher scientific
being the world leader and servicing
science we're seeing a global company
with over 50,000 employees and 15
different countries it's unfair
commercial reach we have unmatched depth
and leading innovative technology and
applications expertise and lab
productivity terminal fishing synthetic
has five band premier brands with
ranging from thermal and thermo
scientific providing mass spectrometers
our fees and other and products to
beauty lab services which provides
customer service for our products so now
let me start really the core of my
presentation focusing on the orbit of
Technology and non-local active family
product so here in this first slide I
want to show you on the left hand side a
typical instrument that you see in
London to see single quadra-port up for
quadrupole and
and wrap this predominantly used for
confirmation and quantitation of a
really known are analyzed orbitrap
instrument on the right hand side it's
really a new new technology for your lab
that not only can be used for
confirmation quantitation but also for
targeted screening unknown screenings
identifying these substances for a
minute unknown substance or substances
as well and being and having the ability
to doing retrospective data analysis
okay so I guess you know the key thing
here is that you can string to identify
with high-resolution accurate mass an
instrument so so why the kids active
focus for forensic laboratory they're
really four key topics here first one
aired versatility versatility the
ability to duck to be targeted screening
to the unknown screening to do and
quantitative content confirming
consummated analysis as well as books
absent analysis the the key exactly
focus provides ultimate performance and
high sensitivity I selectively really a
true high resolution and a great
performance and data acquisition and you
have the data confidence in the results
because of all these key aspects of the
instrument and instrument is really easy
to use and has a really simple
calibration takes about settlements
there's mean no need for optimization
like optimization of transitions and
collision energy like you doing I'm a
quadrupole instrument and its really
able to both platform and last key
feature which is which I only want to
point out with affordability this
product is price competitive to high-end
for quadruple with with all the other
abilities that you can do just like you
do on the triple bottom in terms of
quantitation but you can also be
screening of
target and unknown compound any 3d a low
maintance instruments right so um if I
go to the next slide what is the power
of the herbage what I want to give you a
few technical performance of the
instrument so first being the resolution
up to 7,000 and oxidizer ratio of two
hundred and in turn provides stable
canvas can max apathy of less than 1 ppm
sensitivity is subjective graham levels
with land range over 6 out of 9 a-6
order of magnitude and in addition the
instrument can run from mass range of
fifty to two thousand you can do on the
fly polaris fishing so you can do you
can record one full cycle on the one
second and thirty five thousand
revolutions I think that means that you
can apply a positive and a negative scan
under one second and which requires no
recalibration of the instrument from why
are you doing polarity switching and the
instrument has a software interface
which was modified for routine workflows
for making instrument really simple to
news really a job in Java a drag and
drop method of work of building your
work and 45 experience that you're
choosing to do it's really easy to set
up screening and quantitative methods
which we will see and later it is really
robust in terms of operation with
calibration problem for a number of days
so first let me can you show you
schematic I'm of this instrument so here
we see on the bottom right hand side I'm
source which where the ions are created
in the iron fly into the mix mass
spectrometer to the high reference part
of the instrument where they are select
where they are focus from inside not
towards Ben Slatter ball inside event
possible the ions are
it from the neutral so it kind of helps
to really create high robustness and
reduce any contamination the instruments
the arms are then guided to the
quadruple mask filter where there is the
precursor selection so you open up your
isolation or you narrow down your
isolation wing depending on the type of
different experiments you want to do it
and then go into the sea trap where you
store and cool the islands and there you
have actually sort of a selection you
can either put them in the HDD cell for
an SMS fragmentation then i'm getting
back into the trap or you can direct
them into the orbit wrap on the bottom
on the bottom gear so you can with with
the different type of experiment you can
get a full spectrum so close down
spectra you can get a mess of mass
spectra you can you can choose to just
selecting irons and they select the
biomonitoring or sim modes where you
select it and then because the toys in
do up here and we'll try to explain and
dance in a while so then let me let me
just show you how how your which are
really works so what we have here on the
bottom is we have the arbitrage the
cross-section of the garbage up so you
have here and here two outer electrode
so we call them the outer electrode and
then working in and metal there it's
kobe and center electrode so irons as
you can see a real estate in these
military rank three different colors
they oscillate between the two other
electrodes along the redhawks results of
the center electrode and in this
oscillation actually as you can see need
different speed represent three
different ions of three different masses
and really the quickest the fastest
oscillation between the yellow
represents the low low iron and the slow
is the green one with kayaks so when
these ions are also going back and forth
in this occurring on the other other
electrode and that current actually
creates a transit which is shown here on
the top right hand side and that's
transient if you take a tray transfer of
that and then calibrate it you get a
spectrum and that's it's shown right
there so you have
a mathematical formula with the
oscillation the three determined is that
access is proportionately the square
root of em'll ravines and actually get a
spectrum on the top so that's how the
instrument works in a very quick in
simplified way so now let me show you a
little bit of performance in terms of
Revelations accepting that key aspect of
the instrument right because the
resolution is key performance feature
which allows you to get accurate mass
because when the resolution sign off and
there are many many papers stating that
you need at least 50,000 master jurors
have 200 to get enough resolving power
to be able to separate your hands of
interference from your interference only
then you're able to get the accurate
mass assignment of that compound of
interest so here's just an example of
really calibration mixture to direct
infusion and positive mode of
calibration which we have two things
here on mass to charge ratio around 200
are 195 we have caffeine and shows you
here at that resolution more than 80,000
and then we have a couple of peeps on
the right-hand side these are all
Parliament's and ranging from you know
from 1222 lat master at a resolution of
more than 32,000 to mass to charge ratio
almost 2,000 there with reels of 25,000
so that's what we can expect and all
your on all your samples in this mass
range right so now how does this compare
to and to two other competitors which is
the kingdom's you can see that the kids
active focus resolutions is totally
superior to any and cute off with you
know with three different vendors as a
front put given their ass than arrived
and they're being and you can pick
suppose those are but if you if you look
at the resolution what's very important
here is is really the big difference big
gaps and the low-mass range and this is
very critical for all your small orifice
this is where your markets are and this
is where you need to hire resolving
power to get again to get accurate mass
assignment of your
of your of your target compounds or your
unknown compound ok so now I give you an
example resolution I'll give you an
example scanner to scan mass accuracy
that's really important right because
the bill to measure you know your your
your compound while the LC is running
scan to scan is very important you don't
want to sum up scans you don't want to
you know be able to you don't want ready
to its kind of made some up many scans
and get an average month you want to get
Stan to scan identification and thank
you can a good match IPC unless what we
represented here and as an example we do
carbon substrate no matter composition
there with a resolution setting of
13,000 and we have a five-second else
ebay speech so base to base for us so
they can make about 80 public scans now
if you look at Skansen scan it's less
than 1 ppm as well under + 1 ppm with
the RMS value of frequency 162 ppm
across the peak so that's an excellent
is out there so you can really be
confident with yourself because campus
carry my service is just excellent I
don't have time to show you more but I
can i can mention that it's not just
within 15 seconds I mean this is
actually if you doing that position for
many many injections we an example where
we had about a thousand injections which
took me about 120 hours you seem
confident a strategy throughout all
these injections so you can because
women because instrument and stace
calibrating maintenance and calibration
for a very very long time you don't need
to recalibrate from objection to
injection nothing like that you have to
do with with other instruments so I'm
going to lift out a couple of 10
ingredients y de québec to focus is
better than a cheetah so let me start
with the with the bottom until first of
all you get a one-punch so it's very
quiet if there's only one once again for
fun or gotcha if you're online you but
also your detector right so there is
really a robust detector robust
analyzer and there's no need to exchange
it like NTPC mq does you have
calibration or you have laboratory for
activity with small footprint and really
bench that mass spectrometers able to so
many per meter by meter by meter you
have experimented flexibility so
peaceful easy to use really a
plug-and-play device you have
vascularity switching which i mentioned
in the past so you can quickly get
positive negative silence you have masks
ability and mass accuracy so the
calibration remains four days and two
weeks time and unlike any other
instrument on the market you have
maximum scan scan variation so you have
excellent signal to noise ratio with
Newton's for averaging and its really
hplc compatible you get enough scans for
both screening and for quantitation when
you're using or when you're running hplc
method there's no trade of between
resolution and sensitivity okay so
there's no compromise between resolution
and sensitivity why are doing your fence
and I know that that's the case for
other instrument you have variable
resolving power so you can actually
switch resolution settings so you have
three resolution settings from the moon
to maximum and you can actually play
that and that's becomes are actually a
really good tool for your for your
different types of experiments and after
at the top number one reason really why
why the change active focus but I makita
is because it was precise computation
and I want to really stretch this out
because what you get if you get a
quantitation performance that of a
triple algebra and and and you can do
all the other screening and confirmation
as well so you have excellent linearity
with automatic gain control up low and
high concentration and I'll actually
show you a couple of example of how good
you can count data so first
let me let me tell you there's different
ways of doing consultation on
instruments so you can probably falls
down you can quantitate with sin the
gigantic want a date with PRM and PRN is
our reaction modern so the point that
and analogous with SRM like quadruple
but it's a little bit different than srn
and because obviously we don't have to
quadruples me we have to pause and a
knowledge up at the end so how do a PRN
works is that first you do isolation
with the quadrupole they needed
fragmentation in the HDD cell and then
in the detection with the arbiter
analyzer you get your fragment ions and
MSM inspector right and then you
quantitate it and you did the
quantitation of extracting I'm chromatic
so that's how PRM works very analogous
would say to SRM to guide you that way
and with with kids and differences in
key benefits bears so PRM combines high
selectivity hi sensitively
high-throughput quantitation would calm
confident targeted compound confirmation
right into all of that in as well as
well as confirmation and and I don't
repeat at the screening as well so it's
suitable for quantitating and tens of
hundreds of card compounds in complex
matrices can easily do that and it's
easy and fast to set up so I want to
give you an example of limited detection
and the Nana Grange of cube active focus
vs a than their super quadruple so this
is actually a compound called chief of
commission room and let 30 by actually
overcome doctor prescribed run and this
is an experiment in plus in plasma and
we have the same settings we have in
terms of the LC settings the same
samples no different conditions so same
condition / thank you focus and the
triple quadrupole where we run this
experiment three different and scandals
full scam sin or selected by morning and
PRM with PR ml using that we up to about
1 P P P P the limit of detection the kid
back folk
calibration range from 4 PPTs to about
100 1500 giving these with a dynamic
range of five orders and you can see the
calibration curve on the bottom which is
pretty spooked linear excuse me on only
vendor s to the quadrupole with the FRN
mode the limit of detection is about 1
ppm and calibration range was from opp
fourth PPG's to about 115 ppb's giving
you approximately forward of magnitude
so the calibration range was about 10 *
louis lesce and if you look at the
bottom and television / you see that it
becomes really a nonlinear with the two
dogs circle and red so yes you know in
summer idea is to keep that focus with
Diane mode for NPR ml at the same limit
of detection are they away haiyan jable
and it's a providing ball with linear
with with wider being a dynamic range
Sean from this on this slide okay so and
in conclusion I want to own a kind of
point out two different assets of the
instrument and summarize it really
really quickly on the left hand side I
kind of printed out you think about
calibration and maintenance so you have
five minutes external calibration and
routine that you do when you wake up in
the morning you know and you come to the
lab and you start running the instrument
you can do that right but if you
calibrate the instrument in the morning
on monday it will be fine all the way to
a friday but it's really quick only five
minutes there's no internal calibration
mass calibration needed you can do it
but you don't need it with external
you're pretty fine to get real good maps
and accuracy like I've shown and before
like I said a calibration holes for four
weeks time and there's really very
little influence on mass calibration
with small temperature variation
fluctuation
of course on pop knowledge of the few
degrees but you don't need to mean to
worry about your instrument being
calibrated you open the window or not
the transfer tube is clean within 10
minutes yeah you can actually just
remove it without breaking the backing
and you can put a new one or you can
take that and put it back there and so
you're ready to go inner source
screening you do that once or twice a
year and it's about half a day so
typically i recommend in other customers
to to do that cleaning at the end of the
day put it together and then sent it by
lesser and bake it out at publicist and
bake it out overnight and then you're
good to go on the next day so two
jackets on on the right hand side just
want to show you how to exact the focus
is designed for routine work right to do
your method development right or when
you're doing method really takes a
little to no and that's colored
optimization for each online you don't
need to worry about your optimizing your
indecision or your color are your and
fragmentation energies you don't need to
do anything like that that you do on on
triple quadruple instrument you have
high sensitivity in high selectivity we
can do quantitation without limitation
on the number of one or monetary panel
lines between in addition to your
quantitative aspect you can do
concurrent confirmation of your alliance
using isotope pattern using the fragment
or exact mass you can use retrospective
data analysis which means that once you
acquire data and say you can always
record that you can always go back and
repurchase the same data and look at
things you know look at compounds that
you didn't look before because there
could be something in your data that
you're never really for but it was there
so you can reproduce it you know the
less awkward what we mean by foot
respected data integration and really is
a very affordable shoe high resolution
markets messenger ok so with that I'd
like to thank you for your attention
now we'll hear from Christine Vanessa
Christine Vanetta is a strategic
marketing application specialist with
thermo fisher scientific working on
clinical and pathological applications
from mass spectrometry she has a degree
in chemistry from the University of
California at San Diego and a California
single subject teaching credential in
chemistry this van natta has been
working in the analytical chemistry
field for over 17 years her experience
includes extensive method development
and work performed under both EPA and
FDA glps prior to joining thermo fisher
scientific she worked for roche
pharmaceuticals in palo alto california
where she developed and validated glp
compliant methods on LCM SMS systems I
will now turn it over to news van Napa
thank you for the introduction good
morning good afternoon and good evening
to our viewers around the world today
I'm going to discuss some of the diverse
forensic applications that can be run on
a high-resolution accurate mass orbitrap
based mass spectrometer
the summer works active cuick the thermo
scientific you exact to focus a hybrid
quadrupole orbitrap mass spectrometer is
a highly versatile platform some of the
applications I am going to discuss
include screening both targeted unknown
quantitative confirmation research
applications including the structural
addition of structural elucidation of
unknown compounds and bulk bulk
substance analysis using the dart ion
source I'm going to start with some
screening applications data acquisition
methods for both targeted and unknown
screening are quite similar both
involving acquisition of full scan data
and then fragmentation data the primary
difference is in the data processing I'm
going to talk about three different
types of screening methods the first
method starts with the acquisition of
full scan positive ion data at a high
resolution followed by all iron
fragmentation in the collision cell and
acquisition of the resulting MSMS
fragment data at a slightly lower but
still high resolution this is followed
by a fast polarity switch and the
acquisition of the same types of data in
negative ion mode using this method
compounds can be identified based on the
exact mass their retention time an
isotopic pattern all from the full scan
ms data and then by matching m sms
fragments from the all I in fragmented
data this method also allows for
complete retrospective data analysis
using both the full scan and the
fragmentation data the second screening
method is a slight variation on the
previous method the difference is that
the online fragmentation data are
collected in several precursor mass
segments instead of over the full mass
range at once this improves the o-line
fragmentation specificity and still
allows for retrospective data analysis
as in the previous method compounds are
identified based on exact mass retention
time and isotopic pattern from full scan
data and fragments observed in the all
iron fragmentation spectra a third data
acquisition method provides
greater specificity as previously full
scan positive ion data is acquired at
high resolution here the full scan is
followed by a data dependent
fragmentation scan or I will say DDMS to
that scan can either be triggered by an
inclusion list of specific compounds or
by using the most abundant m / z
detected in the full scan again polarity
is switched and the same data is
collective and ate as a negative
ionization mode in this method compounds
are identified based on exact mass
retention time and isotopic pattern from
the full scan however instead of just
msms fragments we now have a precursor
specific m sms spectra that can be used
for confirmation this is the most
specific screening application because
the high-resolution ms2 spectrum is a
very specific identifiers the trade
offer the specificity is that
retrospective data analysis is limited
to data extracted from the full scan ms
spectra the status still provides exact
mass retention time and isotopic pattern
but we don't have em SMS fragrance from
the all I in fragmented to assist with
the identification of unknowns that were
not in the targeted list here is an
example of this last type of method
implemented on the Q exact of focus on
the right hand side you see the method
parameters we are collecting the full
scan ms data at a resolution of 70,000
and the data dependent em SMS
confirmation data at a resolution of
17.5 thousand ms to spectra were
collected in time windows specified in
the inclusion list with stepped
collision energies to allow
fragmentation of chemically diverse
compounds and to ensure nice full rich
spectra on the left side you see the
mass spectrum method inclusion list of
targeted compounds this particular list
contains over 300 compounds from
different classes which we analyzed to
test this method if we had chosen not to
use an inclusion list but trigger the
data dependent ms to scans based on ion
abundance then we could have also used
exclusion list containing common
endogenous matrix compounds that can be
added to your method this list will
prevent the acquisition of data from
compounds that are irrelevant to your
screening and improve your hip count we
developed the screening application for
urine analysis using a 20-fold urine
dilution for sample preparation in a
short 10 minute chromatographic method
sample preparation was simple dilution
with no hydrolysis a single internal
standard tolbutamide d9 was added we use
this compound because it ionizes well in
both positive and negative modes the
column was a thermo scientific a key
core PFP few score column and mobile
phases were water and methanol both with
10 milli molar ammonium formate for
automated processing of the data we use
talks finder software it is an intuitive
software providing fast data processing
and rapid data review here uski a
schematic of the application workflow
the workflow is as follows in the first
step you create a database containing a
list of target analytes with related
identification criteria the criteria can
include information such as the exact
mass retention time compound specific
fragments iron ratios and other
identification criteria and limits
optional is the inclusion of an m sms
spectral library users can create either
create their own ms to spectral library
or use a library provided by thermo
scientific next users will create a
processing method in which compound
identification criteria peak integration
parameters and report templates are
selected next the sample is this list is
created and processed the data review
step is optional reports can be printed
directly after data processing or after
data review libraries that can be used
in the tox finder software include the
thermo scientific clinical research and
forensic toxicology library and the
thermo scientific food safety and
environmental library the clinical
research forensic library contains over
900 calm
pounds the food safety and environmental
library contains over 1,600 compounds
each library entry includes five spectra
for compound three of the spectra were
collected at single collision energies
and two spectra were collected using
different step two collision energies
this helps ensure detection of your
compounds regardless of the collision
energy you choose for your specific
method
this is the pox finder data review page
from the top left you see an example of
the sample list and to right and to the
right the data review table for a
selected sample the data review table
shows information about the status of
each analyte here I sorted based on the
status the green dot in the confirmed
column indicates that the analyte was
detected and identified with all
identification parameters specified in
the method in this case we used exact
mass retention time isotopic pattern and
the ms2 spectra on the bottom we see the
results for a specific compound found
within this sample in this case
oxycodone on the left is the ion
chromatogram extracted extracted from
the full scan data reconstructed with
the mass accuracy specified in the
processing method in the center are the
experimental m sms vector acquired for
this compound and the corresponding
matched library spectra on the right are
the calculated isotopic pattern for
oxycodone and the isotopic pattern from
the experimental data
moving on from a targeted or we salt
sometimes call known unknown screening
we can now examine what we call
untargeted or sometimes unknown unknown
screening this is the case where you are
trying to identify all chromatographic
peaks detected during an analysis
including those compounds that you were
not specifically looking for for this
data analysis we will use thermo
scientific trace finder software it
performs a two-step process to identify
unknowns in step one is a targeted
search against the local database of
compounds in step two four peaks that do
not correspond to any in the database
the software will propose a molecular
formula based on the mass and isotopic
pattern and then performance chemspider
search on that formula here is where the
importance of the high-resolution and
accurate map data really comes into play
with better math accuracy the number of
possible molecular formulas goes down
thereby decreasing the number of
possible unknowns this is an example of
a compound identified in step 1
lamotrigine in a urine sample was
identified from the database with
information based on accurate mass m / z
and retention time it was confirmed with
the isotopic pattern matching and a
library search not shown here here is an
example of a compound identified by step
2
a molecular formula was proposed based
on the accurate mass and isotopic
pattern the chemspider database search
returned creatinine as a match which was
confirmed by the isotopic pattern
matching as well as the accurate mass
for unknown screening we need a large
number of spectral libraries to match
those compounds to in addition to the
libraries discussed earlier i would like
to present a new development related to
ms to Spector libraries thermo
scientific has established an
open-access Spector database the website
address is MZ cloud org this curated
database contains multiple ms to spectra
and ms to DN spectral trees collected
with multiple collision energies for
compound identification and structural
elucidation as of today the database
contains spectra for over 3000 compounds
it is growing all the time with the
addition of data for more compounds
collected with the help of collaborators
on the left side of the screen you see
just the first five compounds listed in
the database to the right is a spectrum
tree for one of the selected compounds
dopamine and below just one of the MS
two spectra that are stored in the
database
now let's shift from screening
applications to one of them of the many
research applications that can be
performed with the Q exact to focus mass
spectrometer structural elucidation of a
novel compound we know quite a lot about
drugs of abuse around the world
completely new active pharmacophore are
very rare often synthetic analogs are
created by small modifications to known
drugs to thereby avoid detection
targeted screening won't find them since
the molecular weights are different we
can exploit the similar base structures
which will generate similar fragments it
is often possible to identify the
chemical class based on similar
fragments and from and from there
construct a possible formula for an
unknown compound the process is very
similar to finding metabolites of drugs
which we have great tool for we can rely
on the chemical similarity of new
designer drugs to help us find it since
we know other chemical compounds in the
class we can use their fragments to aid
in the search this is a real human urine
sample analyzed and provided by a
customer using an exact of mass
spectrometer with full scan and all iron
fragmentation using another software
package thermo scientific master and TIR
software a fish or fragment ion search
was conducted to try and identify an
unknown compound based on the similar
fragments in the compound class if we
apply this fish what do we find in this
case we found MDPV methylenedioxy paiva
valor own was identified even though our
targeted screen mrs. compound because it
wasn't in our target list the chemical
structure revealed his identity the
common fragments shared with previously
known drugs exposed this peak here in
the pink trace and we were able to start
focusing on this potentially new drug of
abuse
next I'm going to discuss quantitative
confirmation using the Q exact of focus
there are three approaches to
quantitation the first is full scan ms
with data dependent ms ms with this
method you quantitate using the
extracted ion chromatogram from the
precursor massive interest the high
resolution of the orbitrap data provides
selectivity and the m sms spectra are
used for confirmation this method is
useful for samples with less clump
complex backgrounds one great advantage
of this method is that it requires
little method development since all you
need to know are the masses of the
precursor ions a second method is
targeted selected iron monitoring
followed by data-dependent ms ms with
this method only targeted masses are
isolated by the quadrupole and analyzed
in the orbitrap detector the scan is
followed by fragmentation scans of the
same precursor mass this enhances
performance in more complex matrices by
only scanning for compounds of interest
and conversely excluding anything that
you are not interested in the most
specific method for quantitation is
parallel reaction monitoring or PRM it
is the most similar to traditional
triple quadrupole frm methods in PRM
there is no full scan data instead only
the targeted precursors are isolated and
fragmented the data collected is the
resulting high resolution fragmentation
spectra from this you pick quantifying
and confirming ions for data processing
here we have an example of the PRM
method as applied to the quantitation of
six opiates and urine they are morphine
codeine hydromorphone hydrocodone
oxymorphone and oxycodone sample
preparation was hydrolysis followed by
40-fold year and dilution in the lower
left of this slide we see the inclusion
list with all six of the mentioned
opiates and their internal standards on
the right side of the slide are the scan
parameters for this method and the
spectra were collected with a resolution
of 35,000
this is the example of the data you get
from a PRM method on the left is a
chromatogram of the fragmentation scans
for oxymorphone on the right is an m sms
spectra for the compound highlighting to
confirming ions and a single quantifying
iron picked from the spectra
here we have reconstructed chromatograms
of the quantifying ions in the lowest
calibration standards for each of the
six opiates in this method as you can
see you get a good number of scans for
quantitation across your peak
these are representative calibration
curves for codeine and morphine this
method gives excellent linearity and
accuracy across the calibration range on
the right are the reconstructed fragment
ion chromatograms for quantifying and
confirming eyes for each compound again
these chromatograms are at the limits of
quantitation for these compounds overall
this PRM method gave good linearity
limits of quantitation and precision in
both intra and inter assay quality
controls
to test the ruggedness and effect of
matrices on this method we analyzed
internal standard recovery in many
different lots of urine and compare that
to the average recovery for the
calibrators in artificial urine as you
can see we have very good recovery
indicating that this is a robust method
and finally we have some example of
opiates and donor urines across the
calibration range starting from the top
left we have codeine at 12 nanograms per
mil hydrocodone at 60 nanograms per mil
hydromorphone at 37 nanograms per mil on
the bottom morphine at 217 oxycodone at
four and oxymorphone at nearly 700
nanograms per milliliter
for my final application i'm going to
show you an example of bulk substance
analysis using the dart or direct
analysis in real time ion source couples
to the q exact to focus mass
spectrometer specifically we're going to
be looking at the analysis of a
pharmaceutical pill we see here the dart
source easily coupled to the Q exact of
focus mass spectrometer the quick strip
gives you automated analysis of up to 12
samples on the disposable quick stripped
card the source is enclosed to minimize
sample contamination and operator
exposure
sample preparation for this method
couldn't be easier you simply grind up
the pill and deposit a little bit on the
quick strip card and tap off the excess
Leita a data acquisition method is also
simple as the dart source only requires
two parameters the temperature of the
gas and the speed at which the sample
moves through the source the mass
spectrometer data acquisition method is
similar to what we've seen in previous
examples we acquired high-resolution
full scan positive ms data followed by a
data dependent m sms of compounds and
inclusion lists the same types of data
are then acquired in negative ionization
mode
with this analysis we confirmed the
compounds expected in this tylenol
number two pill acetaminophen was
detected in both positive and negative
ionization modes and coding was also
found on the left you see the total ion
krona gram produced at the quick strip
moved through the ion source full scan
and msms cans of acetaminophen and
positive and negative modes and a full
scan and msms scans for coding on the
right you see be positive and negative
acetaminophen spectra and the coding
spectrum we use stocks finder software
to process the data here we have the
results for acetaminophen in positive
ionization mode on the left is the
reconstructed krona gram from the for
the precursor compound in full scan in
the center is the experimental MSMS
spectrum and the corresponding library
match spectrum and on the right is the
experimental and calculated isotopic
patterns
in conclusion what we have seen here is
the versatility of the Q executive
focused hybrid quadrupole orbitrap mass
spectrometer for forensic applications
it can do everything from screening for
known and unknown compound to
quantitative confirmation you have high
confidence in your results thanks to the
high resolution and accurate map data
and the ability to use multiple
identification and confirmation criteria
provides high specificity sensitivity
precision and robustness thank you for
attending today's webinar
that's my presentation thanks for
bringing that information to us before
we get started with all of your
questions here's a quick reminder about
how to reach us today questions can be
sent via the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll get to as many as we can and our
first question is in your opinion Red
Mill routine labs move away from old
technology like triple quads to these
new HR am based on orbitrap for both
quantitative and screening on one
platform I believe just watch for
watching oh yes I'd things thanks for
the question and good afternoon and good
morning to everyone so yeah that's a
very interesting question and why I
travel around the world to too many
different customers I see that now and
now and now adays customers demands is
you know much more than just targeted
list of compounds and I've been saying
this for a number of years where
customers are buying the exact fit for
bacup instrument to do a number of
different words in the lab and there's
more in our lives that I see their
customers are completely giving away
from from typical odds because they want
to not only one state the target
compounds but as well went to identify
the unknowns and the non-targeted
compounds in their samples so you know
it's a trick question but when would
this happen but from what we can see is
that it will be a few more years I
believe that no this type of routine
work will completely go into high res I
quit mass instruments it don't come from
on the orbitrap instrument my this
product used only in forensic labs ma
chaine um what's not it's it's it's not
just for forensic lab but always
actually for any small molecules and
especially routine application so this
instrument is not be done for proteomics
absolutely not but it is design for
routine day-to-day work on its
simplified method either it simplifies
from control software you can we can
obviously run it like we showed you here
and music for forensic toxicology but
you can also use it for food analysis
and environmental screening water as
well thinking water sewage water if you
will use it for fun silica applications
so it's not just for forensic toxicology
would of course this was the topic of
discussion here today and machi this was
for you too how is the Q exactly focus
different from the Q that is plus yeah
so the kids active plus is a really
high-end instrument design predominantly
for proteomics application it has a very
different hardware there are several
things are quite quite different like
the logical for example is segmented
quadrupole as opposed to on a hyper
quarter form on the kids active focus
which we showed today it has a protein
mode enhance resolution Lord fit it is
very different and in a way performing
instrument that does a huge I said and
beginning for proteomics applications
and for that it's not really a viable
instrument for for repealing workload
this next one I believe this was for you
Christine how
servos LCM SMS news let's see use for
designer drugs of abuse constant change
okay thank you for that question I
believe we have some grammar issues but
I'll do the best I can I believe they're
asking how can these instruments find
the new designer drugs that are
constantly changing and with in these
screening applications when you're
running the full scan data you will
always get the parent mass so when you
go back in the retrospective data
analysis you can go back and find those
new compounds you can see if it was in
your previous samples and also as soon
as one of these new designer drugs is
identified and isolated and we obtain
the spectra for it and that spectra will
go into MZ cloud and you will be able to
search on the new designer compounds if
you're searching for these new compounds
yourself you will have to use some of
the other software that I showed your
match frontier and do that do a little
more sleeping to tease it out yourself
okay and Christine here's another one
for you how many compounds can be
analyzed in screening applications the
screening applications can handle a
virtually unlimited number of compounds
whatever since you're not going to be
detecting all of your compounds in all
of your samples even if you have a very
large inclusion list or a very large
database of compounds it's only the
instrument will only be taking data
dependent spectra of the of the
compounds of the masses that it sees at
a high intensity so because of that you
have a virtually unlimited number of
compounds that you can that you can look
at and again we're the first game data
you will have your complete precursor IM
spectra that data collected to go back
and look at it anytime what sample
preparation method and what elsea method
would you recommend for screening
application
Christina bleep this will be for you
well for the screening applications we
recommend a simple and generic sample
preparation method for urine it would be
simple your involution for blood or
plasma or something like that a simple
protein precipitation we have seen
posters where people have been using
mixed mode or multi analyte sample
preparation type columns a two to four
sample preparation the key in screening
since you have such a wide variety of
compounds you want it to be a very
generic sample preparation method so
that you don't lose any of your samples
during sample preparation and also for
the LT method we have some nice columns
the columns that I have shown here work
very well and we often go to a neutral
pH on the mobile phase 2 again
accommodate a wide variety of compounds
polar and nonpolar acidic and basic so
those are my recommendations okay and 24
to let people know that polls are being
shown on the screen please respond to
them and we have another question in
Christina's would be for you can you
easily swap heavy ionization source
sources with George oh very easily these
sources are very easy to swap out
there's no configuration in the software
required good very minimal the physical
transfer of these sources is just a
couple of thumb switches to pull it off
and put the new source on and then in
the case of the dart to also hook up
some some gas to make sure that's there
and it can be done in literally less
than 10 minutes okay give me a moment
here I see it may be that more questions
are coming in and we're trying to pause
for a quick moment
okay well I believe we will conclude now
and if we did not kick to your question
today if you can just send its question
if we did not get to it we will follow
them up with you via email I would like
to thank our speakers today dr. McKeever
mirsky and Christine de nada as well as
our sponsor someone Fisher Scientific
for making it possible to bring this
presentation to you today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through april first 2016 you will
receive an email from us alerting you
when it's available on demand and posted
on lab routes comm you are welcome to
for this announcement to any colleagues
who aren't able to join in today Thanks
blogging on and participating in today's
broadcast see you next time